who is absolutely enthralled by his own
earnings. He has a garden and he is just
fascinated by this garden
and he comments to himself.
[Silence]
He says about his garden,
"This garden, I cannot imagine it will
ever see an end." How could it? This
garden is too important. He had a huge,
huge garden. And of course he had
workers and he had and he was supplying
the town with with work and with money
and he became very influential and
perhaps even the town's economy and and
commerce all depended on this garden.
And so he started to naively think that
he was the center of the universe that
he could not be done without. What would
they do without me in my garden? My
garden will never see an end. It can't.
Because if this garden were to be
eradicated and be no more,
how could people survive without it? The
entire world hinges on this garden. The
hubris.
And I I really don't believe that there
is such a thing as judgment day.
However, if there is a God and if there
is judgment,
then if this is what God gives me here
on this earth, imagine what he has for
me in the next life. Because obviously I
have been given this wealth and this
garden and this position
because I am very special,
right? And so what did Allah do for him?
He completely
eradicated that garden. Left nothing of
it.
He destroyed that garden entirely. Why?
Because it was critical for this kind of
attitude
that humanity be taught that this
attitude is the beginning of the end.
and these beliefs.
I mean, if you think about it now,
imagine the richest man in the whole
world,
you know, whoever that is. Let's say
this person has
hundreds of billions of dollars. Let's
say he has trillions of dollars.
That person, what do you think is going
on through that person's mind?
in when they sit with themselves
what do they really believe about
themselves I am merely a servant of
Allah I am merely a caretaker of Allah's
gift this is by Allah no
the person believes that I am the
smartest I am the greatest I am the best
I'm the most important God in the
universe quote unquote would not have
given me all of this wealth if it wasn't
for what they know about me.
And this marked a time when the Muslim
would live as neighbors with the
non-Muslims and they would not be
governing the non-Muslims nor would they
be governed by them. And this is the
early days of Medina.
The next story we have is the story of
Mos
and that marks the era of when the
companions
began to travel, study and teach. And
then finally we have the story of
who who possessed every part of the
known world of his time. And that marked
the time when the Muslim reached all the
way to the Atlantic Ocean and all the
way to the Pacific Ocean. Every piece of
known land at the time was governed by
the Muslim.
And so this surah surah
it marks and details every single stage
that this ummah moves through and it has
the entire history of this in it and
even when this you know this u this
atrophied it atrophied in that order as
well.
He will cover me.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the first and opening verses
of the Quran, his book, his final
revelation to humanity, The greatest of
all miracles and all books and
revelations
ever bestowed upon humanity by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He begins his book
with the verse with the words in the
name of Allah
the extensively
unimaginably merciful
and the especially merciful.
He follows this by saying, "All praise
is due to Allah."
All praise, all thanks is due to Allah,
Lord of all of the creation.
He is the extensively,
unimaginably,
unmitigated,
unbridled,
merciful one. And he is the one of
specific and a special mercy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches his
prophet in the early days in Mecca and
if Allah afflicts you with any harm,
none can remove it except for he Allah.
And if he is to give you any good or if
he is to touch you with any mercy
then he is able to do all things and
none can stop that mercy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes his
creation and says every single thing
that has been created by Allah has been
measured perfectly and created with a
destiny.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
this is alquran
the lofty and brave
and esteemed Quran
and it is in the preserved tablet of
destiny. What do all these verses mean?
What is the pattern that we are seeing
here? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches
us our place, our position, our
attitude, our disposition. And he
teaches us what he is and who he is.
He teaches us as the first lesson when
we open the Quran,
the first lesson that he teaches us is
alhamdulillah.
What an incredible lesson. What an
incredible belief.
This is why our ancestors, our
forefathers,
our predecessors,
the companions of Muhammad Sam.
This is why they were so extensive and
expansive.
This is why Islam has reached us here
all the way at the end of the earth.
at the end of time because they
understood this lesson.
The lesson of
and alhamdulillah when we go to start
something
when we look at the future the present
and the future we say this made up. When
we look at the present and look at the
future and conceptualize the future, we
look at them through the lens of bismah.
In the name of Allah, I ask Allah for
help. I depend on Allah alone for this.
I seek in Allah everything that I hope
and desire and I seek refuge in Allah
from any and everything that I fear.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us to
believe in him and to take every step
in bismah
to take every step seeking that help and
aid from Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
what a beautiful verse
and the meaning of
[Silence]
creation.
Oh yeah.
And then
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala teaches us in
just this one word
these two words
the person is saying, "I seek aid in
Allah and I praise him with every name
that is his, every name of his that I
know and every name of his that I do not
know. I seek aid in Allah in this."
That is the meaning of this.
And Allah teaches us who to rely on
that we have that
we always think the absolute best of
Allah.
When I go to start something, when I go
to try something, to attempt anything,
I attempt it with
and I follow it with.
This is who I believe Allah is.
He has enveloped me in his mercy from
the moment of my conception.
Everything that I have ever been, ever,
or ever will be and every good that I
have ever achieved, it is only by Allah
and Allah alone. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. He
has never let me down before. He has
never betrayed me. He has never turned
away from me. He subhan Allah has never
forgotten me before. And so I call on
that same Allah in this moment and I say
my heart is open and full of hope in
Allah.
That is the first lesson of the Quran.
It's not I believe in myself.
It's not you have to love yourself first
before you love anyone else.
It's not look deep inside and pull out
your own strength. None of that. That is
for the birds. That is what those who
are lost on this earth who do not know
where they came from, who they are,
where they are going, and why they
exist. That is how they think. We the
Muslim, we don't believe in ourselves.
We believe in Allah. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
We look to Allah. Every good that we
have or ever will have, it is from
Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
any good, pleasure, ease, comfort, any
good
that any of you have, it is only from
Allah. He is the one who is the author
of every smile that has ever crossed
your face.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala is the author of
that.
And so Allah gives us something much
better and greater to believe in than
ourselves.
He gives us himself to believe in.
And if we could just teach our children
this,
if we could teach them that every time
you go to do something, every time you
go to attempt something, I want you to
think back at every good that has ever
come to you and remember that that came
from Allah. And that even when things
went in a way that was contrary to what
you wanted, you wanted things to be a
certain way, but they went a different
way and it ended up being better. And it
is what has arrived you at this
junction. That same Allah who doesn't
just give you what you want, but gives
you what you need. I want you to imagine
with me
a parent who gives his child everything
that he wants. Everything
my child anything that he desires I give
him and let let him do. Would we
consider that a good parent? Dad, I want
to go play in traffic. Go ahead. I don't
want to break his heart. He's expressing
himself. He's finding himself. This is
how he goes and expresses himself and
learns about his own existence. He is
learning to author his own book. So, who
am I to say no to that? Who am I to deny
that? Want to set fire to my study? Want
to go ahead and leave the doors
unlocked? You want to go with that
stranger to his van? You want to go play
in traffic? You want me to throw you
over the fence to go play with the
lion at the zoo? This is not a parent.
This is an insane person. And we would
agree that this person not only is unfit
as a caretaker but is positively
deranged.
Yet we expect this from Allah.
We with our little three lb of gray
matter that we have between our ears. We
think that we figured out the cosmos and
everything that I want I should get
because I know the best. Even though
each and every one of us disagrees with
ourselves last year, if you were to go
back to last year and have a
conversation, you would look down on
that person. You would disagree with
that person. You would scold that
person.
Let alone if you were to go back 10
years, 20 years, and speak with your
former self, you might not even be able
to stomach looking at yourself.
Yet in spite of that we are convinced
that at this moment we know what is best
for us. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us about the human being. He says
the human being has been created
and composed of haste itself.
The human being was physically created
from mud, from dirt. We know this,
right? But the human being is so hasty
that if someone were to say that the
human being was created by hate from
haste itself, he would not be far off.
The human being is so shortsighted, so
plagued
with inconsistencies, so plagued with
conflicting emotions. How can you trust
yourself?
We don't. Allah taught us to place
ourselves in his hands. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
He taught us to ask Allah to give us
what we need and not what necessarily
what we want.
We don't always get what we want from
Allah. And that is a very very good
thing.
Just a caretaker cannot give to his
child everything that he desires or that
would mark the end of that child.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
watches over us. He takes care of us.
Allah tells us
Allah teaches us that the human being is
so shortsighted, so ignorant,
so pathetic in his current state of
knowing and wanting that the human being
makes and prays with the same fervor and
fury.
for what is destructive for him that he
does when he asks for that which is good
for him. The human being prays
desperately, I want this particular
thing. I want this particular woman. I
want this particular job or car or house
or whatever it is. I want this. Please,
please, I want this.
But this person doesn't know that if
Allah were to give him this thing, it
would mark his demise. It would be the
beginning of his end.
And so the human being prays in his
ignorance for that which is
bad for him with the same fury and
fervor that he does for that which is
good for him. And the human being is so
ever hasty. Allah tells us how can you
trust a creature that?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam didn't.
He used to say every morning and every
night,
"Oh Allah, I trust in you. Take care of
me. Be the rectifier of my affairs and I
ask of you. I beg of you, Allah, to not
place me in charge and to leave me to my
own devices for even the blink of an
eye.
And then we learn from those around us
that you have to love yourself and
believe yourself. And it sounds very
poetic. Sounds very nice. It's a very
nice oneliner because we live in the era
of oneliners.
Pathetic statements that are very hollow
inside. What does that mean? I need to
love myself before I can love. What does
that mean?
No, we find our love in Allah. We find
our hope in Allah. We find everything.
We find ourselves
in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
A person is only defined when he defines
himself and his worship of Allah.
Who are you truly? You are who you are
with Allah when it is just you and
Allah. That is who you are.
And so the prophet sallallah.aihi was
every morning and every night for 23
years
he asked Allah every sunrise and every
sunset. Oh Allah, be the disposer, the
custodian of my affairs and do not leave
me to my own devices for the blink of an
eye.
And that is what makes Islam so great.
That is why that light of first coming
to the prophet Muhammad Sam
and the dark of that night in the dark
of that cave. When that light pierced
through that darkness and he came and
held our prophet and he said
That was the greatest gift humanity had
ever received
because we have the greatest in the time
of
the time before Islam
when they would want to make a a big
decision
they would go there to the Ka and there
was a custodian there around the
capital. They pay him a few dollars and
they would ask a question and then reach
into a bag and pull out a lot. Three
sticks in a bag. One said do it, the
next said don't do it and the third was
empty or try again. And so when they
want to make a big decision, they go,
they pay their few dollars and they
close their eyes and reach into that bag
and wait to see what the sticks tell
them to do with their lives.
Or they would roll dice. Or they would
look at a pigeon or a a bird sitting
there and they throw a rock at it and
watch. If it goes right, that means I'm
on the right track. If it flies left, oh
my goodness, I have to go home.
If they see a little lizard,
they would throw a stone at it and watch
which way the lizard crawled and that
would be an omen of good or bad to come.
That is where humanity was. They were
asking magic eightballs figuratively
what it is they should do with their
lives because they believe that those
sticks were the conduits of the greater
universe.
The universe is going to tell them and
direct them. How pathetic.
They even did this with respect to the
lineage of their own children.
When a woman did not know who the father
of her bastard child was, she would go
to the cabba, pay the custodian with the
suitors there, the five or 10
prospective fathers, and they would draw
lots and whoever it fell on, hey, you're
the dad.
This is how they lived.
And then Islam came
and
tells us
[Silence]
And then Islam came and and Jab comments
and says the prophet Sam
taught us the salah of
just he would teach us a verse of
the Quran. And he told us that if any of
you is torn between a decision between
two options, pray
make pray and say the following.
Oh Allah, I ask you by your knowledge.
This is what we were given. We don't ask
sticks and magic eightballs and flip
coins. We ask Allahbin.
So our first lesson was
what a what an incredible lesson.
And our second lesson that Allah teaches
us is alhamdulillah.
Allah doesn't give us what we want. He
gives us what we need. And sometimes we
want what we need. But most of the time
we don't.
The disease always fights against the
cure and the medicine.
And Allah, he doesn't want to break us.
He wants to better us. And in order to
make someone better, you have to take
him to the cutting edge of friction.
In order for him to shed his old heart,
to shed his scales,
to get out of that and to grow and to be
better.
And so today's psychology is hinged on
two philosophies.
the philosophy
of the allegedly
both of them were Jewish
psychologists in Germany
that we have Freud and Carl Young. Freud
teaches us that humanity is driven
purely by sexual urge purely.
This man was so sick that he believed
that even a a child with his mother or
father that this is based in
urges whether you have or not.
And that every dream you have, every
statement you make, even the way you
walk or speak, every decision you make
is nothing but biological urges.
And then we have the second Carl Young
who believes that we're all part of one
great consciousness
misguidance upon misguidance
about but we have the Quran
and that one lesson will change your
life. We all know these things I'm
saying. This is not new. If you will
have the bravery, the courage, the
courage
to truly live between bismillah and
alhamdulillah, your life will change.
Everything will be different. Your
attitude will be different. You will not
be able to help but smile.
because you live between this and
alhamdulillah.
I ask for the best and I take whatever
Allah gives to me and I thank him
because I don't know what is good for
me. He knows and I trust him because he
is
for
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
straighten your rows. Please do not join
the row. do not join a row until you
are sure that the row ahead of you is
completely full.
If you remember to bring your phone,
then remember to turn it off and make
sure that it is silent.
[Arabic recitation]
Brothers and sisters, just wanted to
remind you a couple of things here.
First, the summer camp is still
continuing. We have five more weeks and
the enrollment is open. So if you have a
child under the age of 14, they can come
and join inshallah.
we also have Rahma Academy looking for
teachers and please contact Rahmed Java
and at least get the information see if
you can find some you know help us with
that spreading the word. We are looking
for teachers for Rahma Academy. Also our
brother
brother Dr. Ast
Sard his father is sick in the hospital.
Please make dua for his speedy recovery.
May Allah call us
heal all the sick in the community and
in our families inshallah.
Please donate generously all the way
out.